what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to low loaded featuring
push iced
link up before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel
and hit the notification bell
okay as you guys know not a big
like rap person don't know too much
about this stuff
someone sent this to me on instagram so
if you guys want to submit a video send
it to me on instagram
okay
[Music]
hey run that [ __ ] up chase
[Music]
okay
okay so i'm gonna just interpret this
really quick what they're talking about
is the opposition they got like a party
right and they're trying to beat them to
the party
probably to like stir up some trouble
you know what i mean i got a party i
just got the load i bet you i beat him
i bet you they see me there this time
time
got my dog in the cell
[Music]
you think with your gun what
what is that even one card down get up
in that [ __ ] 12 on a half so i hit my
glitch that's fair time [ __ ] that could
that switch real life war zone on with
that [ __ ] let's smoke great bluffs i
meant that [ __ ] watch them out for them
songs better fix that [ __ ] big backwards
smoke no swiss
[ __ ] baby with a drink how to switch
that [ __ ] engineer go down when you mix
that [ __ ]
okay so what i gathered is that he's
very
he dropped a lot of terms about
different weapons and he's not afraid to
use them that's
that's what i got from that little
snippet like a draw when i hit that
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] with you from me
some [ __ ] i'm
[Music]
[Music]
big clock in my hand but we all got rich
but the whole gang slide we all on
missions all y'all snakes [ __ ] all
y'all hissing
okay so he's saying that when his
friends are successful
um that that's good and you know he's
happy for him
and then they're all successful together
but there are like snakes
and they're hissing so he's saying like
his friends that aren't really his
friends like they're snakes
they're mad because they're successful
got a party i just got the load i bet
you we beat him there
we go
[Music]
i have no idea what he just said i will
kind of want to re-listen to it i know
you guys hate it when i do this but i'm
going to go
i need new sponsors
[Music]
okay so he's effing them up when they
send me the drop
what does that mean the draw like the
address from the helicopter i'm 200 and
no one will never start
well no wonder they're going to beat him
there if they got a helicopter you
wanted to go we got plenty of shots
there's a body on there ain't no problem
okay so they're drinking and doing drugs
at the party i got whack but you got the
other dog when it time to go slaughter
take my revolver yeah it says a little
[ __ ] been loaded
the rollers check them percocet make
sure they cold shout the cop
so much till i broke it no ain't no more
clubbing for office when they send her
low getting motion get on point up any
call with me you know we fully focus
this one here was okay these two sneaky
get the closes so they [ __ ] i'll go
like a troll and all my ten by five
percent when we creeped up he couldn't
he know to give up
anything if you owe me we slash it like
[ __ ] loading the ice got a party i just
got the logo
slime [ __ ] like nickelodeon okay so he's
talking about the slime
like at the slime awards i don't know
what that has to do with like the party
maybe there's going to be slime at the
party
i bet you they see me there i've got a
party i just got the love i bet you i
beat them
they're really excited for this party
really excited
like they're they're excited to have a
good thing
[Music]
some cool cars this is one of the few
rap videos i've seen that had like no
women in it or maybe there were more and
i just forgot about them i don't know
uh i was not a fan of that song not
necessarily because of the lyrics
i just didn't like that i couldn't
really understand what they were saying
with like the ad-libs in the background
and i just wasn't that big of a fan of
the beats i'm gonna give this one a two
out of five
as you guys know one to five scale is my
favorite i think it works a lot better
let me know in the comments if you agree
or you disagree do not forget to
subscribe to the channel
and bring the notification bell i'll
talk to you guys next time